today i've decided to talk about the
lowercase letter greek letter gamma
which is the symbol for a photon
so lawrence gam a gamma i understand is
the symbol for a photon
is it i
i didn't know that so this is a
difficult one because this is actually
sort of intersects with quantum
mechanics in that
there is this strange property of matter
that sometimes it behaves like a wave
sometimes it behave like a particle
a photon is a quantum of electromagnetic
radiation or if you like a quantum of
light so
in the usual wave theory of light we
think of light as being electromagnetic
waves propagating through
space they can propagate through a
vacuum a photon is a little packet of
light energy with the advent of quantum
mechanics we also know now that the
energy in
in
light waves
comes in little bundles so to me a
photon is something like a little
cricket ball
with a with a bit of momentum a tiny
amount of momentum and a tiny amount of
energy
and uh the momentum that it carries is
given by planck's constant divided by
the wavelength of the light
[Music]
astronomers sort of use both sometimes
we think about light as a wave sometimes
we think about it as a particle so the
the detectors we use for example in the
backs of telescopes these little things
called ccds which are the same as you
know in the camera that's pointing at me
at the moment um the technology they use
entirely relies on detecting individual
photons an individual photon arrive and
gets recorded by that detector so every
time you're hit
uh by a photon it's just like taking a
hit with a tiny tiny quantum cricket
ball now the momentum of one photon is
extremely small so we just don't notice
it and if we're standing out in sunlight
it's hitting us nearly all directions
but you can actually exploit the
momentum of each individual photon
for example in space travel so you could
imagine uh having a spacecraft near a
star and then if you put up a great big
sail a big area sail that can catch the
photons or even get the photons to
bounce off in reflection the momentum of
those photons
can then uh accelerate the
the
the spacecraft without need of any
rocket fuel you can just use use the
momentum of the photons coming from a
nearby star
and if you wait long enough from a big
enough sail you can really get up to
quite high speeds well we do look at big
huge things really far in the distant
universe but the only thing that we can
really detect from those distant
galaxies is
the light that comes from the stars and
that light is actually in the form of
photons of different energy so when the
photons
reach our telescope and happen to land
on them then we can turn that into a
signal and an image of what the galaxy
looks like one of the things that
astronomer that's sometimes useful to
think about
is people think about wave packets so
you think about a photon as kind of a
little packet of waves all going along
together
and that's kind of a slightly uneasy
compromise between these ideas of
thinking about light as a wave and
thinking about it as a particle um but
it is it's again not capturing the whole
essence of the thing it really is the
reality is it's some complicated mixture
of the two that you really can't
describe in such simple terms uh when uh
say a nucleus takes a hit
from
a a photon it recoils because of the
momentum that the photon has delivered
just as if you were hit by a fast
cricket ball you would take a hit and
bounce backwards and for the americans
who may watch this a cricket ball is a
bit like a baseball it's hard and heavy
and it hurts when you hit you hits you
and so an energetic photon can
give a hit to a to a proton
[Music]
well it's nice to know that photons come
from very distant galaxies but we also
have
a reason to study photons on earth the
only reason we can see is because
photons are received on our eyeballs and
we can interpret those as different
images and also we receive photons from
the sun so the only reason that we have
light during the day is because photons
from the sun scatter around in the
atmosphere and come down to to brighten
everything up
do you see them as little bits as tiny
balls or do you see them as waves which
which is in your in your head
i suppose professional physicists are
taught and it's ingrained in them to
think of it both ways to think of it in
terms of way particle duality so
i mean they're very everyday objects i
mean we we experience light all the time
but they have these mysterious quantum
properties as well
in places outside of england it's often
that the sky is blue
yeah
yeah okay i'll take your word for it
okay a few days during the year in
england the sky is blue and we can
understand why the sky is blue because
of the way that photons from the sun
interact with our atmosphere so photons
from the sun come
from many different energies and some of
those are actually scattered off of all
the particles that are in the atmosphere
so the scattering depends on the
wavelength of the photon
and the size of the actual particle
that's in the atmosphere so most of the
stuff in our atmosphere is oxygen
or nitrogen there's some other stuff too
but let's say we've got an oxygen
particle right here and we have some
sort of red light from the sun coming
through traveling with a really long
wavelength it's essentially going to go
right over that particle whereas if we
have blue light that's traveling with a
very short
wavelength then it's most likely gonna
bump into that particle and get shot off
scattered in any direction so if the
blue light is being affected and
bouncing every which way why why isn't
less blue making it down to earth and
hitting my eyes and the sky appears
unblue
well
since the blue light is scattered in
every direction then you've got blue
light coming from every direction
whereas you've got a collection of all
the other types of light that come to
your eye so you only actually see the
blue light in that case which is why the
the sky is blue
the path that the sunlight comes through
during the day
is the shortest path that it can come
through the atmosphere when it's
directly over your head
so
in the evening if the sun is way over in
the west and it comes from here then it
goes through a longer path in the
atmosphere so more photons get scattered
and more photons get scattered so all
the blue photons get scattered and then
the yellow and then the green so the
only ones that are actually left to get
to you are the red and the orange so the
last ones that scatter and the ones that
actually reach your eye are the blue or
the orange and the red when the sun sets
so that's why we have red and orange
sunsets now if we didn't have any
atmosphere the sky would be completely
black just like space just when
astronauts go up
they see a black
a black space around them they don't see
a blue sky or an orange sunset but we
can do a very nice experiment to
demonstrate why the sky is blue show me
this flashy setup all right
so this is our fancy setup to simulate
why the sky is blue and the sunsets are
red and orange here we have some water
with some some stuff in it to simulate
the particles that are in our atmosphere
and we've got a flashlight that comes
from the bottom which simulates the sun
coming from a distance for for those
english speakers flashlights a torch
so the sun enters our atmosphere
and we see that some of the wavelengths
are scattered so the shorter wavelengths
are scattered more efficiently and we
see those as blue here so you see kind
of a blue glow in the same way that you
see the blue sky during the day now if
we think of when the sun goes through
more and more of the atmosphere so
if the sun if this is the earth and the
sun shines down straight to us it only
goes through a little bit of atmosphere
at noon during the day but as the sun
sets it starts to go through a lot more
of the atmosphere to reach us here so as
we go through more and more atmosphere
we're scattering more and more of those
short wavelength blue photons so that
what we're left with is actually the
longer wavelength orange and red photons
so when the when the sun sets the sky
looks like this part up here where we
have a really bright orange light and no
more blue